et d'abord donc la condamnation sans
appel de jacques santer à propos du
rapport qui a motivé la démission de la
commission européenne
il récuse en effet les conclusions de ce
rapport et se dit choqué que quatre ans
de travail soient réduites à néant
jacques santer qui affirme que les
irrégularités sont des cas particuliers
tout en montrant du doigt son
prédécesseur jacques delors pascal
verres d'eau par nasri à bruxelles à son
arrivée à la commission ce matin jacques
santer était presque serein comme
soulagé
pourtant la journée promettait d'être
rude nous avons pris nos responsabilités
politiques cette clarification c'est moi
prix les voulu en pleine crise
européenne jacques santer que l'on
disait mou et effacé défend l'honneur de
son administration et son bilan j'ai été
choqué par la tonalité des conclusions
que je récuse je n'avais pas qu'un bilan
de 4 ans de travail au cours desquelles
cette commission a réalisé intégralement
son programme politique soit ramené
ainsi cas d'irrégularités dont 4 remonte
avant 1995 c'est à dire avant d'entrer
en fonction de cette commission
pas d' attaques non plus du président
sortant contre et qui créent sont
épinglés pour favoritisme mais peu
loquace dans les couloirs
face aux journalistes étrangers je crois
qu'on peut repartir à partir de là dans
la construction urbaine sur de
meilleures bases avec une réflexion
approfondie que de toute façon on
n'évitera pas sur la façon de
fonctionner ensemble pour sa part
gerhardt schröder est arrivé avec un
message limpide priorité dans quelques
jours à berlin à l'agenda 2000 la
réforme du financement de l'europe et
petit coup de griffe en passant à 100
ter le rapport hier du comité des sages
est un travail sérieux
il faut renforcer encore le contrôle sur
la commission en fait la commission de
bruxelles affirme avoir manqué des
moyens humains et financiers pour
assurer l'ensemble de ces tâches de
gestion et le débat de fond est lancé
que peut-on faire de cette commission
un organe de propositions comme pour
l'euro ou une simple administration
chargée de gérer les programmes